hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to SCP containment
breach now I learned something
interesting and you just saw it in that
map there even when I'm just standing
here 1 7 3 goes and does whatever the
hell Billy wants to do you know 909 6 is
still there and I'm now in the entrance
zone which is awfully nice and so I
don't know how to use that to my
advantage but I think I'm going away
from everyone ok so that's not good
they're in here now oh boy I don't know
which direction they're coming from but
they're not going to like me very much
if they find me oh ok where is this what
is this what is this and where is this
where is this and hang on let me save
boy after five Commander bridges by 860
and the change in its UTM coordinates we
have finally convinced the o5 to send
agent Azumi Junko inside 861 last time
the key materialized in front of someone
the trio the researcher committed
suicide before we could take further
actions perhaps or lack of exposure to
the last two exploration logs is what
makes her so eager to go into that place
I've seen them and I'd rather splatter
my brains than go in there right now oh
I have the key I have the key oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] II fall oh I can't close that door
ok hang on let me put this here read
this ok 860 there yes I have that oh I
have that I don't know why I have that
but I have that ok put that anything and
this ok 860 is used to unlock and open
the door the door does not lead to its
usual destination instead it opens into
a small forest clearing of an 80
centimeter wide footpath every
observation if this girl's knows the
presence of blue colored mist so there
is
yes there is you know and I'm going to
stop that train of thought and I'm just
gonna go in to it because I have saved
and I am ready I'm ready to go so let us
go and let us do this I don't know at
the point of this is I can't remember
but here we go again into the darkness
oh yeah I remember this I'm gonna put on
my running mask good there's so you know
what I think I think I'm gonna enjoy the
sights just over a little bit cool this
is where my best friend in the whole
world is come out come out wherever you
are
Marky's here to find you oh [ __ ] yeah
cuz I don't know it's like just that
thing is bad enough to make bad happen
Thunder if it's not I guess something
seems to have gone wrong the moment I
entered the force communication with the
researchers was lost my headset is
playing soft music and said it's very
calming the blue hues beautiful and I've
never felt more and he's in my life oh
you too I feel so relaxed look at how
relaxed I am this is my relaxing smile
oh yeah a choice god it's been so long
it's been
hi Wadley [ __ ] you followed me in
here really god dammit okay [ __ ] you and
[ __ ] all of you but not my friend in the
woods he's my friend and he'd never hurt
me for as long as I live he would never
hurt me more choices sure
okay you know what sure I don't remember
there being this many branching paths
before Oh another note great funda BA
I just noticed but the path here is made
of cobblestones that is odd I recall
being made of dirt when I first entered
the forest I'm hearing howls in the
distance but they don't seem aggressive
it's like they're calling to me warm
lights shine between the trees my
headset keeps playing music oh yeah no
I'm sure I'm sure it's totally fun and
fat happy and friendly okay clearing
oh no not clearing just choices again
why Oh
okay let's try this again shall we
and this time don't turn around cuz
turning around is death
also I'm going to hurry up because I
seem to be far behind
well that's not a good sound something
barn we know I'm totally calm by the way
by the by I am 100% calm Oh seems a lot
more malevolent than the last time I
went in here oh oh oh okay okay
dead ends are bad so I had been making
the right choices hmm gotta just follow
the breadcrumbs II everything's fine
everything's fine
Flipboard okay so I gotta make the right
choices URL thundered mmm mmm okay which
way eeny meeny miny moe mmm Hey Hey look
at that hey I got it
Oh what what oh oh I made it I made it
oh [ __ ] hi no no no no I just I made it
I made it here don't [ __ ] on me like
that buddy but don't don't don't you
[ __ ] dare oh oh oh oh [ __ ]
okay okay are you gonna open that door
I don't know if I'm clear what the
hell's going on to the left there but I
was about ready to sprint I'm still
ready to sprint into that door again not
that I want to [ __ ] God we would like to
advise on surviving personnel once again
do not attempt to reach the exits either
find a safe area or go to one of the
many evacuation shelters inside the
facility I didn't know there were
evacuation shelters I wish I would have
known about that Oh No okay I don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on over there but
I don't think they're coming over here
[ __ ] what are you doing right fine
you know what they're making a clean
sweep I can't even see the my man list
but they've got to be there's s EPS that
are nearby the [ __ ] are they Jesus
they're right there they're not mistaken
right they're right on the other side of
this door and then scp-096 and 173 are
still around here where the [ __ ] oh
they're gone
Oh what the [ __ ] is going on are they
there or aren't they [ __ ] [ __ ] no
don't do it please
I don't want to die okay well I don't
under I I'm I'm very confused and Billy
what the [ __ ] I didn't even know that
was possible
like what the what the [ __ ] it's hard to
do a gym face on you but just like what
the [ __ ]
so I don't know what else they're doing
but man they're good at their job why
aren't they just stationed here all the
time
oh please I don't want to I don't want
to die I would rather not if you could
just move on that'd be great
it's dick he's still got one 7-3 around
here I just going oh that was that door
okay okay this is bad I don't think
there's any way for me to get out of
here I think I'm just kind of stuck oh
yeah cuz they seem to be they're
thorough these guys they're thorough
okay I think they may have gone like I'm
not 100% sure
again I'm not on a percent sure but I
think they're on they're on they're
taking scp-173 away to containment
I guess oh oh oh oh hi hi hi I give up I
surrender oh [ __ ] hell
oh damn it oh man they are good at what
they do and what they do is so doji all
right fine what was even the point of
going through there is that like the
only way to go down that area oh my god
that is insanity
all right you know what I'm trying to
I'm I just try to sprint through as fast
as I can
I know the way to go whoa hi I see okay
you're Wow hi
okay you know what don't have time for
that ain't nobody got time for that and
I certainly do not
so I know the way to go so I'm gonna go
in as soon as I can
okay here we go there we are okay all
right so we're on the other side so I'm
just going to go for it I don't know
where they are but I'm going to oh [ __ ]
oh oh oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh oh
oh [ __ ]
oh hi no you don't see nothing just take
oh [ __ ] oh I'm going for it whoa whoa
whoa Medical Bay that sounds great can I
have some of that medicals
oh hello dead people in the medical Bay
oh I've got a syringe of of some sort do
I need that for stomachs honking hi hi
hi hi what the [ __ ] no I came here for
boy then whoo oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh boy oh boy what clothes okay all
right I don't like that anyway I don't
like that at all I'm gonna go over here
now real slow like because apparently
I've been hit
Jesus I'm probably dead oh [ __ ] I'm
going [ __ ] I'm dead oh boy that's not
good I'm going to die because I got hit
by a zombie didn't I didn't I yes I
think I did yepper deckers I better not
save because otherwise I'm dead but
here's the door control I'm going to
course we would like to advise all
surviving personnel once again do not
attempt to reach the exits
either find a safe area or go to one of
the many evacuations online why are you
just you know just shoot me I'm I'm
gonna die anyway just just shoot just
just shoot me just yeah any minute okay
there you go
Wow
that is crazy
oh [ __ ] but anyway uh at least I know
where the door control is now and I
don't have to cook that way I don't have
to go through there so I'm going to
figure more of this out in the next
episode thank you everybody so much for
watching hi buddy and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]